it was a bold idea four years ago Halga
schultz are founded the egg box company
near the city of shravan a co-worker had
the idea of making egg cartons out of
corrugated cardboard they're sturdy and
offer plenty of room for printing
designs the concept took off right away
and was especially popular outside of
Germany today exports make up two-thirds
of egg box sales the merchandise here is
on its way to switzerland in a few days
all of these over here are heading to a
big discount chain in austria we also
deliver to greece Scotland's South Tirol
wherever our customers are located only
four machines do all the work at egg box
along with eight employees the company
is successful despite its modest
resources CEO Helga schulter says that's
because foreign markets provide
opportunities to improve the quality of
his products by the umpire orders from
abroad are very specific they want new
formats different materials or different
colors on the cartons it's not always
easy to meet these demands but we're up
to it Venus count out new ideas bring
new customers and increasing prestige
today more small companies than ever are
setting their sights on foreign markets
in the eastern state of
mecklenburg-vorpommern an area not known
for its economic strength foreign sales
have quadrupled over the past 15 years
more and more small companies in and
around the state of shredding a
conquering foreign markets client and
clients don't and compared to larger
companies small businesses have fewer
resources to prepare themselves for
doing business abroad that means that in
addition to taking care of daily
business managers often have to work out
a foreign sales strategy I have a lot of
respect for managers who can pull that
off Phyllis he'll go shelter is one of
them he's now creating an egg box
designed for a customer in Greece
shelter says dealing with different
languages and mentalities can be a real
challenge but there are benefits to
you this is unheimlich fun it's
incredibly exciting when you fly over to
Scotland for example and talk with the
people there you see how they live then
they show you around you learn how
people there do business and every day
is different even talk vida another what
started as a simple idea has grown into
an international business and sales look
set to take off they've already been
inquiries from Africa Asia and Australia